hey what's up y'all this Kyle over here
at the GQ tower with my peeps and these
are my essentials the first one is an
optimistic attitude you bring it with
you everywhere that's the first thing
you need to bring all right next up on
the essential list actually wow I can't
tell you the name of it so I tell you
the name of it then everybody else is
gonna have it just know you need to get
yourself some cologne okay if you don't
smell good ain't nobody gonna talk to
you nobody talk to you you're gonna have
a very meaningless day definitely
cologne is top priority essential high
dome boom these right here
okay Apple earpods they're just so
perfectly designed so that you can be
wearing them right be for real doing
your own thing as I say you're having a
business meeting let's say you're
playing Nipsey Hussle because he's like
arguably the greatest ever all right and
then somebody's like said something you
can take it out everything stops you
focus on what that person saying you're
like sick I love you too mom and then
you go back to doing a ding they're just
perfect these make life way better
don't fall asleep with these on a plane
though and that's how you know they're
essential because the moment I lose
these I have to buy them very essential
right here Nintendo switch ok this
revolutionize my life I'm not gonna lie
prior to having this I would just really
go through these like withdraws from
video games right cuz like I'm addicted
to that like I love it now I'm on the
plane and instead of crying on the plane
because I can't play xbox or something
like that I was like oh you know no fear
now pretty soon everybody's just gonna
be doing this
[Music]
great issue in the world vans and
randomly enough my very first job ever
was that Vance and I fell in love ever
since this should be a part of
everybody's wardrobe I've had at least
over 100 pairs events at my lifetime and
I don't know what it is it's like dad
style shoes just don't look dope on me I
think it has to do something with the
like size of my head I'm being so
serious I'm being dead [ __ ]
I think it's in direct relation with the
size of my head my body to the shoe
needs to be more like it has to be Vance
that's the only thing I look dope in
also essential part of every rapper's
repertoire is small amount of height so
with me I like to do my eyes in
moderation I went to my homie Big O in
LA that's my jeweler and yeah man he
made me this this guy right here this
little dude and maybe this will do to
match with it it's like it was like a
little more subtle you know I like
subtle eyes I don't want to come in just
with like a bunch of [ __ ] clanking on my
chest like it's not tight
essential part of any productive
person's life macbook pro baby yeah dude
this is like this is like home this is
like you know this is like your office
like when you're here you're working or
maybe you're just watching YouTube
having fun either way I wouldn't be
getting nothing done if it wasn't for
this man bro
[Music]
so this for sure hey what's up yeah no
no I'm just telling people about how
this phone is the greatest creation ever
made so anyways like I was saying iPhone
very essential even though in that sucks
you know I mean that sucks that we have
to keep these on us at all times
actually enjoy that my phone is broken
on the side so it doesn't really ring it
doesn't even vibrate it's just silent
[Music]
what is the most essential thing when it
comes to essential things the thing you
carry all of your essential things in
aka this bag right here the back is been
with me for a minute I first actually
got it in New York when I was shooting
this movie in New York is like not
forgiving you know I mean like there's
nowhere to push it down you know I mean
you got to walk everywhere so I was like
dude I need some type of bag to put
everything in it having [ __ ] in your
pocket sucks cannot have things in my
pocket I will scream dude I'm wearing
the - this tooth right here it's gold
it's got a little diamonds in it shouts
out it's a big oh he made this tooth umm
this is very essential for me to turn
him from Kyle to SuperDuper Kyle right
gonna pop this buddy in it's like all
systems go I'm ready to start the show
you feel me this was like 2015 when I
had over make it and so many people kept
telling me like well you should get
braces you should do this you should do
that dude I couldn't afford braces my
entire life I already went through the
whole process of getting made fun of for
having you know crooked teeth and I had
to adapt on how to deal with that
already so I'm already past that stage
now I'm just gonna like you know now I'm
just gonna celebrate it and so I wanted
to get this gold cap on this big shark
tooth of mine I made unique teeth a
thing
and so did Steve Buscemi he kind of
helped with that too so my next
essential and my best essential is
booyah Jesus everybody this is the most
essential thing if you don't have
somebody like Jesus get somebody like
Jesus in your life I'm not this that's
his real name
okay that's his name don't have me thank
you guys for checking out my essential
things hope you all have a great day
hug your mom or hugs am i close to you
let them know you love them yeah you
know hey feel free to hit me up you know
hit me up online I'll be passing our
compliments all the time you know say hi